hello everyone welcome back to the kappa
blanka saga we are back at the 1914
tournament of some picture burg and we
are at the final round of this great
tournament
it's horrible uncle with the white
pieces against Alexander yeah in a last
game monka played against a canadian was
able to draw the game against capablanca
for the first time in his life so here I
think Alan is the more relaxed but I
think it's important to mention that you
know a lot hangs in the balance here for
capablanca he needs to win this game
against Todd akin to still be in the
race for first place so it's basically
like this Capablanca needs to beat a
legend in this game whereas last her
face his friend James Marshall in the
front in the final round
so if Lasker wins against Marshall
Alaska is the sole winner of the 1914
tournament of sank Peter Berg if Lasker
draws against Marshall then last round
Capablanca shared the first place and if
Marshall beats Lasker and the cup a cup
of vodka beats 1110 Capablanca wins the
1914 tournament for son Peter Berg it's
an excellent game before we check out
the game I just have two short
announcements first I've started a poll
about I will be starting a weekly
tournament on leeches so you are here to
decide on the time format the first
thing you will see in the description
below is a link to this poll so you will
need to decide where you want to go 1 1
+ 0 1 + 1 2 + 0 3 + 0 shorter time for
much longer time formas will be avoided
you know to minimize cheating but you
know just you need to drop your vote so
I know where to go from there and
another thing if you've enjoyed my video
on awake was great - victory against
Fabiano Caruana
and the other day the grand HS classic
youtube channel published a video with
peter like oh where he analyzes the game
and he just it's really impressive
you'll learn a lot how to play against
the deadline of the Queens gambit
declined at Quora wanna played the one
with a 6 and also you will enjoy
learning how to play it really an
insightful video at the second link you
will see in the description below will
be a link to that game on greg HS
classics youtube channel and that being
said let's check out this very nice game
kappa blanka has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 i didn't go
he's six the Horwitz defense is asking a
cup of longface he may be interested in
transposing into the French and
capablanca is he goes efore we have d5
Knight to c3 and not Knight to f6 the
classical variation of the French and
Bishop to g5 and here the standard idea
is for black you would capture and then
after captures go Bishop e7 and here
white can just trade everything with say
Knight captures captures captures
captures one out of three and then the
game just continues black was able to
really some of the pressure and the
black will just have an excellent game
but alien goes for a different line and
also and maybe I forgot to mention it's
all the same to idea him whether he wins
or loses this game alien has secured a
third place in this tournament with h6
attacking the bishop here Bishop
captures on f6 Queen captures on f6 and
bounty captures on d5 11 wins the bishop
pair from the start but Capablanca wins
a pawn
now of course you don't want to capture
and along Knight captures there are no
useful tricks here even if check in
Knight can just retreat blog the check
so all is fine here for Capablanca after
each capture Sun d5 Bishop to b4 bialyan
and okay Bishop to b5 now with check
Capablanca wants to secure his extra
pawn we have c6 d captures on c6 now
comes Knight captures on c6 and nights
to eat oka Blanca is ready to castle 11
castles we have castles back Blanca as
well and now Rogue d8 so capablanca
still up upon but now I didn't will
transfer all of his pieces to attack the
the D pawn so capablanca gives up the
light square bishop as well to secure
his extra pawn first Knight to e4
attacking the Queen Queen to h4
violation and now comes Bishop captures
on c6 also defending the knight here B
captures on c6 and now you do have to
defend the night you could try something
like Queen d3 you could try f3
but Capablanca goes for the most active
plan f4 now blocking the Queen's attack
towards the night so what does alia
Hindu here first he develops a bishop to
a6 a nice developing move connects rooks
also it comes with a nice pin here
controls the f1 square
in the future cup of monkeys most likely
to push a 5 bust open DF file and he
would definitely like to double rooks n
DF file and as long as this bishop
controls f1 should be a pretty tough
thing to achieve for pepper Blanca and
now c3 kicking the bishop back also
strengthening the center here Bishop
back to f8 and now just Queen to e 1 cup
of vodka now says I'm up upon my
position is better let's trade Queens
and you know I'm just gonna beat you in
the endgame
I didn't of course is not interested in
this we have Queen to h5 not with a
double attack against the night here and
now rook to F do we have c5 I didn't of
course wants to get rid of his isolated
pawn here so he uses it to attack up a
bank a strong center Knight captures on
c5 Bishop captures and c5 pawn captures
and Queen captures pinning the rook here
and now just night to d4 a nice move by
Blanca the knight is firmly placed on a
dark square in the center
I didn't has a light square bishop so I
didn't does not have a single piece he
can use to kick this night away from d4
so this is an excellent outpost I
wouldn't call it a monster night just
yet but it is a fairly fairly nicely
placed Knight rook to d5 here I didn't
take this opportunity to double rooks
along the default and he wants to push
he 5 to further activate his rooks we
have h3 capablanca make some room for
his king which will prove to be quite
essential as you'll see later rook a to
d8 now just doubling rooks and Queen to
e3 now now Kappa Blancas rook can also
move and with E 5 s plan bialyan with F
captures on e5
rook captures on e5 and now Queen to f3
getting the Queen out of the way but
also with an attack against the f7 pawn
Queen to e7 defending and here it's
interesting I allows Capablanca this
very nice fork which Capablanca plays
Knight to c6 you can see the Queen is
under attack the rook is under attack
the other rope is under attack and also
the is-7 ponies under attack so what was
aliens idea here first rook to e1 check
rook captures we have Queen captures and
of course you cannot walk with the rook
as we mentioned the bishop is still
controlling the f1 square so it's quite
handy that Capablanca played that h2
removed to make some room for the King
kink - h2s plate and now rook to d7 just
guarding the f7 pawn we have Knights to
d4 back and here it seems like a very
nice idea for addition to go Busch up
the b7 but Bishop to b7 is quite
unpleasant for black actually after rook
to e2 here Capobianco could use this
tactic to trade Queens and now you have
to trade Queens of which favours
capablanca he's up upon and if you try
to let's say queen bee want to take
control of this diagonal you don't wanna
sorry this diagonal you don't want to
allow rook to e8 check followed by Queen
f5
you could go Queen g4 now attack the
rook and after the rook moves and now go
just h4 prevent this rope from coming to
g5 and after black prevents another
check let's say Ruby 8 now you go Knight
to a5 and already black is in huge
problems you're threatening checkmate so
after g6 you can just capture here the
King g7 sorry
if King g7 then Knight captures on f7
and well you're just you're just lost
here check you have to move you captured
the rook and the black will very soon
get checkmated so after Knight d4 Bishop
to b7 although seemingly an excellent
move not really Bishop to d3 first you
cannot capture it because the rook hangs
on f2 and it will be a very useful piece
controlling this diagonal and here
capablanca plays Queen to g3 a very nice
move and now comes the Queen to be one a
couple Blanca could be thinking of rook
to f3 with the idea that he will either
force a trade of Queens and because
there will be a double attack against
the bishop on d3 so I can will not have
any any say in this
so first Queen to be 1 violation and now
Queen b8 check King to h7 and now comes
Queen to EA now attacking the rook on d7
and here we have looked a b7 and here
there are some ideas here well of course
you don't want to play rook captures on
f7 it's an idea but bunch of g6 just
wins the game for a day and you will not
be trading anything you
you're just gonna lose your look so here
a couple vodka please a beautiful move
after Luke to be 7th couple month ago
Knights to e6 and now it's a wonderful
position you might want to just enjoy it
for for a few seconds what's the idea
behind it the idea is quite simple once
you want to see the moon id6 after pawn
captures just rook a fate and there's no
way to prevent checkmate the queen is
controlling g6 rook 2h8 will be
checkmate
i didn't of course cannot allow this so
i didn't find a sneaky move Bishop to b5
Knight to FA check is a huge threat but
at least now after this move which now
wasn't played the King has to move the
knight also controls g6 so after King g8
you still don't have any nasty
discoveries because first you have to
deal with your queen being under attack
so first after Bishop to b5 couple month
adjust moves the Queen we have Queen to
see it attacks the rook and now rook to
e7 attacks couple uncas night here and
here Knights f8 to check so what do you
play here if you play King to h8 then
the game is just lost for you after an
IG 6 check this comes with a double
check from the knight and the Queen the
rook is under attack so after king h7
just Knight captures here the knight
control g6 n g8 Queen to g8 will be
checkmated there is no way to prevent
this so after Knight a faded with King
to g8 no it's a bit different now Knight
g6 isn't all that impressive because
it's not a double check I think could
just block it with rook to e8 so couple
monka finds a different plan Knight to
d7 check blocks the bishop control of da
square King to h7 and now comes here
kappa blanka played Queen to c5 with an
attack on the bishop and the rook also
Capablanca could have forced an endgame
here it's interesting that he didn't
wouldn't like to f8 check King Jade and
now go into this line that we mentioned
rook e8 blocking and now Knight to e7
check King f8 and now Queen to f5
would force a trade of Queens here you
are forced to trade here because there's
the threat of checkmate either you're
gonna do that or lose the Queen so after
Queen captures Knight captures
Capablanca could have entered this
endgame being up upon but he decided
against it instead he went to Queen to
c5 now attacking the bishop and the rook
I reckon first uses this opportunity to
bring his queen back into the game Queen
to e1 defending the rook but also if the
bishop is captured alien picks up
Capablanca stroke an f2 but Queen to a5
check and this is the critical moment of
the game alien is in check what do you
do here so feel free to pause the video
and try to figure out how to go about
this with the black pieces just you know
a nice a nice exercise for those of you
who were able to do it and defend
properly congratulations you are an
excellent defender and for those who
just want to enjoy the show King to g8
if you played this this is what I can
play this is a huge blunder but if you
found g6 which is actually the best move
then you are an excellent defender here
you allow Knight f6 check but after King
g7 the Queen has to move and here black
the defense properly on the other hand
the move I'll even play this King to g8
and this simply doesn't work but it's
interesting why doesn't work so again
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find it the winning move for
kappa blanka i'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
are able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent winner of games that
must be won and for those who just want
to enjoy the show
Queen captures on d5 simple but you know
very effective and now here's the
problem if you play Queen captures on f2
then this is this is the problem Queen
be a trick pink to h7 and not just nice
to f8 check forces the King back King g8
and not Knight g6 comes with a discovery
and now you lose the rook King to h7
Knight captures here and you are down a
piece and also Capablanca will be
controlling this diagonal so I reckon
could not use it you know harass the
White King so Queen B 5 deadly you
cannot grab the rook
either he now has to go for rook
captures on d7 but now Kabul Annika
doesn't capture and allow captures here
first
rook to a two attacks against Queen
Queen d1 you have to protect the rook
but now comes Luke - eh check King to h7
and now Queen to f5 check we have g6
here and here cover Lanka just plays we
tewi 5 again simple but but so effective
this is just beautiful you I thinking is
not in time to offer a trade of Queens
here because of rook 288 this would be
checkmate
so I even has to give up a further
material with f6
at least to make Queen d6 come with a
check but it's all just for show I guess
how Queen captures on f6 is played again
rook to h8 an unstoppable threat of
checkmate Queen to d6 check now is
played forces a trade of Queens which
capablanca doesn't mind with captures
captures and here kappa blanka just
played rook d7 check again moved his
King to g8 and now comes Luke captures
on a7 and it was in this position on
move 45 that Alexander allien resigned
to the game
what if you resign well he's down three
pawns those are three connected passed
pawns and those are extremely fast so
you don't I mean that there's no point
in any point in playing this there's no
way to even blunder it would be
impossible to even imagine black not
losing this game so Aria hidden is not
interested in this but yeah couple of
Anka wins the game and now the most
important question how did the last pair
play against Marshall well I think it
would be best just to show you not that
but here it is these are the final
standings of the 1914 tournament of
sankt-petersburg
there you have it as you can see in the
preliminary cross table this is the
first part of the tournament a couple
uncle won this as you all know with a
point and a half ahead of everyone
last group with six and a half I didn't
with six and a half but then the final
cross table it's Alaska who wins the
tournament with 13 and a half points
altogether because Alaska played the
greatest tournament of his life here in
st. Peterburg only losing one game it's
the first game he played he was stood
against the on off ski in the first part
of the tournament and then just you know
continued crushing the tournament so in
the second part of the tournament the
one that was played between last couple
on Caliente rush and Marshall Alaska
only drew two games and won the other
six so that's insane so it's actually
Lasker who wins the 1914 tournaments
sankt-petersburg
no it's in the couple Blanca saga this
is actually you know this is this
tournament belongs to Emmanuel a square
he's just totally dominated it and I
decided 40 for the end of the in the
middle of the kappa blanka saga maybe
maybe to show last year's win against
frame james marshall the game that won
this tournament just as a bonus video to
the kappa blanka saga and also maybe i
thought of showing the names of each
versus start of the game that should
have won the brilliancy prize also as
maybe a nice bonus addition to the the
9014 tournaments of st. Peterburg so
there you have it
prizes amounted to these five players
were rewarded twelve hundred eight
hundred five hundred three hundred and
two hundred rubles I don't know how much
this this was back in 1914 I mean if you
just go to a currency converter it will
twelve hundred rubles will be like
eighteen and a half dollars today but I
found a website that converts this you
know due to the inflation and everything
in those days it was something between
$500 and and nine and a half thousand
dollars so I don't really see how this
website does it but if any of you do
have any idea how much this would be in
1914 do share in the comments we will
all like to know very much so there you
have it and also an interesting thing
here we have it a bit more nicely placed
last card with 13 and a half Kappa Lanka
with 13 11 with 10 sig Bert iris with
eight and a half and fring geum's
Marshall with 8 so you know next time
you're in a bar with your friends and
they ask you how come Akiba Rubinstein
only had 5 points and Emmanuel Esther
had 13 and a half
I mean Alaska wasn't so much better than
Rubinstein but then you will be able to
tell them that Rubinstein did not
qualify for the second part of the
tournament and so he will not continue
accumulating points like Alaska and five
five of the other players swam that's
basically it and I decided to include a
short message from Capablanca it's from
Edward winters book he included it in
there so let's just enjoy it a few words
from josé raúl capablanca about this
tournament so there we have it to my
compatriots once again luck has smiled
the world champion I have a point behind
in second place can affirm that it was
not the superiority of my opponent that
defeated me but the draining of my
strength I played 14 games in the
tournament without losing a single one
despite my poor health since a few days
before tournament sorry since a few days
the event began but later I could no
longer resist the task was beyond my
strength in the end game against marshal
in the 15th round I weakened for the
first time and the fact that I won the
game was due to the great advantage I
had last cards opponent in the 18th
round is not the same person who in
round 5 and 13 had the world champion on
the brink of the abyss capablanca talks
about himself as he was better in the
first game against Lasker much better in
first game against last pair and second
game against Lasker and then losing the
third game to that unfortunate idea
where he just should have exchanged the
bishop and then take the d4 square from
the last person I'd sorry about that the
game against Arash in the 19th round was
a disaster that was one of a couple of
the biggest blunders in his career I had
the better game but in the moment of
utter blindness I lost a piece and with
the game and the first prize which
everyone thought was in my pocket
against Marshall in the 20th round I
risked everything and had a little luck
recovering my strength to some extent I
want a difficult ending against early
action in round 21 this is this game
we've just shown my position was easy my
opponent would be third whether he won
or lost whereas I if I lost I would be
second by one point if I want I might
come first since Lasker could lose
against Marshall if Lasker drew he and I
would share first in second prizes we
already mentioned that my opponent gave
up a pawn for an attack I maintain the
advantage and playing much better than
on the previous days managed to win
Lasker for his part launched a direct
attack on the King giving up a piece for
the irresistible position on a move 29
Marshall resigned and everything was
over well ask her first with 13 and a
half okay we already said how much
everyone had what comforts what comfort
can be derived by my compatriots and by
me there are several points burned the
celebrated English master now too old
for such a contest although he had the
right to enter described in
his field column one of my combinations
in which I sacrificed a piece a
beautiful move which irresistible
reminds one of morphe Tuhoe style of
play that of the young Cuban undoubtably
bears and a very great resemblance
playing like morphe means playing like
nobody else and we can be very proud of
these words of mr. burns speaking of my
last game against Lasker mr. burns says
the game is no criterion of the Relf
relative strength of the two great
players Capablanca is evidently out of
form only a match could decide who is
the better of the two this point seems
to have been clarified halfway through
the tournament that is to say the
general opinion not only of chess
enthusiasts and average masters but also
of great masters is that the battle for
the world chess crown will be between
Lasker and me we we have gained a great
deal I have finally convinced nearly
everybody that if there is anyone who
can take the title from Lasker it is I
and nobody else the style of Morphy they
say and if it is true that the goddess
of fortune has endowed me with his
talents the result will be I will not be
in doubt the magnificent the magnificent
American master had the most
extraordinary brain that anybody has
ever had for chess at the unique
strategy tactics knowledge which is
inconceivable for us all that was
possessed by morphe 54 years ago one
example in his theoretical knowledge of
the openings did not exist so to speak
yet what more if he played 56 years ago
against the Petrov defense is considered
today by Lasker and me to be the
strongest continuation for white we
already mentioned that in our previous
videos but here is the very important
part finally the most important thing
from the practical point of view the
evening before last after the official
prize-giving the organising committee
offered us a dinner as I was being
toasted by mr. PP sabor of the president
of the Committee of the all-russian
chess society dr. Lasker and his wife
approached me with their champagne
glasses at a drink to my health and for
my success now interesting move by
Lasker we were thus reconciled and
shortly afterwards dr. Lasker spoke to
me about the matter which interested the
chess world the World Championship as is
well known he has to play against
Rubinstein as last Rose already agreed
to play Rubinstein for the World Chess
Championship match and once that match
is over I am convinced that there will
be no difficulty in arranging terms
under which I shall play the victor
before concluding I wish to add that I
have received a number of cables a cable
means a telegraph sent by cable from
Havana from the private secretary of the
President of the Republic from mr.
Patterson on behalf of the colleagues at
the State Department from the
municipality of Havana signed by dr.
Sanchez Quiros at the proposal of mr.
Ayala from mr. Marquis sterling
president of the Havana chess club from
the municipality of Mariano to all of
them I offer my most sincere thanks for
their congratulations regretting that I
did not have the strength to give them
the pleasure of congratulating me on
being undefeated perhaps in the next
tournament I do not lack the will or the
courage
so there you have it a short message
from kappa blanka about this entire
event where he played a brilliant
tournament but then at the end of the
the second part of the turn he just
couldn't keep up and the Alaska played
one of the greatest tournaments of his
life where he just completely
obliterated the field yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you are still enjoying my coverage of
the kappa blanka saga so far I also said
that I will most likely include Alaska's
win against Marshall as a bonus to the
Capablanca saga but we are you know most
likely gonna return to 1914 Tremezzo son
Peter but at some point as we've only
covered couple bonkers games and there
are so many great games here we could
cover Rubenstein's games Marshalls games
tarz games Louis Chris games of course
I'm still waiting to get the great book
by dr. Siebert arash about to this
tournament so I'm sure we will be
returning to it but the I just
considered this to be like a nice bonus
maybe yeah don't forget don't forget to
vote on my weekly tournament the first
thing in the description below the
second link in the description below
check out Peter Lucas video about his
victory over over Caruana
wonderful stuff this will be the second
link in the description below do check
it out I would like to thank Jonathan
Miller now as rabid or rich earlier now
Wesley Carter and Alexandre George for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully what's a more
interesting content checking up on your
suggestions
doing the two bonus videos and then
we'll
consider where to go with the cup of
Blanco saga from then but you know I'm
sure we'll manage so thank you all and I
will see you soon